alright so there are some that argue
that the Empire Strikes Back is the best
Star Wars movie ever made
I respectfully disagree the Empire
Strikes Back is one of the best movies
ever made period call it the best Star
Wars movie ever made is just cutting it
a little short The Empire Strikes Back
alright just a spoiler alert a fair
warning I'm going to talk about the
Empire Strikes Back like you either know
all the spoilers in this movie or you
just don't care you have been warned
alright so the Empire Strikes Back takes
place some time after Star Wars and the
Empire is pursuing the rebels big time
you don't blow up the Death Star not
have the Empire be like oh ouch alright
you're all dead and this movie steps it
up in just every way possible I'm not
talking special effects even though it
did have better special effects I'm
talking in terms of character
development script execution the stakes
are higher in this one in every way
possible it steps it up
first of all we'll take Vader Vader is
just a hundred times more evil in this
one than he was in the original Star
Wars movie he did some bad things and he
killed some people for sure but in this
one he's just executing lieutenants who
fail him he was like nope I'm choking
you with my mind until you die no
there's no grand moff tarkin to stop me
this time I'll stop when you stop moving
like Vader's in this hyperbaric chamber
thing you know it's this little weird
bubble thing that he kind of swivels
around and talks to his guys on the TV
and chokes him with his mind you know
it's all good but this is one scene
where this one commander comes in you
see the back of Vader's head right
before the helmet comes on and his head
is just trashed it's all scarred up he
has no hair that's the first time you're
like whoa you mean he like needs that
robot outfit he doesn't wear it for
style
Vader's actually a damaged dude that's
awesome and he rocks it to he's like
yeah I know you saw that it's no big
deal
I'm just that badass you want a scar too
now cuz you want to be like me so the
rebels are all hanging out on Hoth it's
an ice planet perfectly isolating no
one's going to find them there until you
know the empire does the Empire's
strolling up with their 8080 walkers and
if they get close enough to the base
they can blow up the shield generator
and the rebels are screwed why the
Empire didn't just take a ship down just
right on top of the shield generator and
blow it up that way cuz we wouldn't have
the battle for Hoth but you see from the
opening text not only is the empire
pursuing the rebels but Darth Vader is
pursuing Luke Skywalker with a vengeance
to the point where he's even going down
on Hoth personally he's like alright
let's find this guy we're taking him
down he
he is mine and that's one of the changes
that I hated for the DVD version
generally speaking in the special
edition I had no problems with the
changes they made Empire Strikes Back we
see the wampa we didn't see him before I
thought that was alright he gave the
Cloud City windows that was fine it was
less claustrophobic it felt more open
perfect but in the DVD he switched the
actor who played the Emperor within
McDermott the guy who played the Emperor
and Return of the Jedi and the Star Wars
prequels what you would think would make
sense except he changed the dialogue the
dialogue was fine before and it fed into
the movie emperor was like oh hey we
have a new enemy it's Luke Skywalker
invaders like yeah I know he's bad news
but what if he can be turned that's why
I'm doing what I'm doing after all the
new dialogue has to accommodate the
prequels now Vader has to not even know
that Luke is alive the Emperor needs to
tell him this is the first time in the
new DVD release that Vader even finds
out that Luke Skywalker is this rebel
who blew up the Death Star which really
brings into question why is Vader
following Luke Skywalker if he doesn't
even know he's his son apparently he's
following Luke Skywalker adamantly to
the point of going down to Hoth
personally to make sure that he's caught
just because well he's a rebel that blew
up the Death Star and you know personal
touch and all that I need to get
involved now it doesn't make sense so I
hated that he changed up the dialogue
for the DVD release now the Empire
Strikes Back has a couple of my favorite
moments in movie history one of them is
when Luke's hanging upside down in the
Whomper cave he's hanging there and his
lightsabers just out of reach no way to
get it now we saw in the original Star
Wars movie Lucas force-sensitive he did
a couple things when he was you know
sparring with that probe and he felt the
force you know when he blew up the Death
Star a new window launched the Rockets
but we never really saw him use the
Force to this extent this is the first
time we saw that Luke is actually on his
way to being a Jedi he's hanging upside
down then he focuses himself and he
reaches his hand over and you see the
lightsaber just creep up you know he's
using the force he's getting the
lightsaber lightsaber pops right out of
the snow into his hands he's back in
business it's one of my favorite moments
in movie history one of the two that's
in the Empire Strikes Back and also what
I liked about this is it divides the
crew usually a movie like this will find
a way for the original crew in the
original movie to all get together and
have the same campaign just in a really
forced kind of way this was like nope
Luke has to go to the Dagobah system to
learn from Yoda then Han Leia Chewie and
the two gay robots have to escape the
Empire it's awesome it's perfect the
movie set up to where you see Yoda you
don't know he's a Jedi yet let alone a
Jedi Master
he's really
testing Luke and being really annoying
he wants to test his patience to see
kind of what he's made of
look of course fails miserably as he
will in every test in this movie in Yoda
humbles down he's like her not ready are
you another scene where Luke's like I'm
not afraid I can learn Yoda looks really
creepy like he's stoned and methed out
and he's like it will be yeah well as a
kid I was always like meanwhile while
Luke is on Dagobah training with Yoda
himself the one who trained obi-wan
Kenobi not qui-gon Janet I don't know I
don't know how he came up with that it
was Yoda they told us in Empire Han Leia
Chewie all of them are in bespin hanging
out in the Cloud City with Billy Dee
Lando's awesome dude not only is Han
Solo a sweet awesome smuggler but we got
another one this movie just doesn't get
better we got to cool smugglers and of
course what are friends for but to
invite han and Leia to a luncheon to
hang out you know just you know chill
we're all friends here
but Vader's there and Lando betrays him
now everyone gives Lando [ __ ] for this
but no one really thinks it through we
don't really know what Vader threatened
Lando with me what if Vader was like
okay you're gonna give up han Solo
or I'm gonna skin every man woman and
child in this Cloud City until you do at
that point what can you say except [ __ ]
I guess so man I lost the [ __ ] I have
the Falcon bag and why does Vader want
han Solo well to torture him of course
why because Luke will get visions of
that and Luke will come to Vader that's
all that Vader wants everything Vader
does in this movie is all to get Luke
Skywalker
Luke's freaking out he's like I gotta go
I gotta help him Yoda is like don't do
that you're gonna make it worse obi-wan
Kenobi comes down in the form of a ghost
he's like yeah listen to him
I believe this so adamantly that I am
haunting the Dagobah system as a ghost
to tell you to stay here because he's
going to toast you or turn you which is
no good to anybody
the last force user in that galaxy turns
to the dark side we don't want that but
in this movie
Luke fails every trial so he goes to the
cloud city upon all this bubble fest the
one that actually found Han Solo and
told Vader where he was he's going to
get frozen in carbonite which is Vader's
plan to do that to Luke but in order to
test it he doesn't want Luke to be
killed so he's going to test it on
Captain solo why not
Solo dies he won't do it to Luke no
regard for Han Solo and his problems
whatsoever
Vader's a douche in this movie one of
the best douches ever this is one of my
two favorite moments in movie history
that's in the Empire Strikes Back
pawns about to get
we're down to baka starts freaking out
throwing stormtroopers everywhere and
he's screaming he's making a ruckus han
solo's like Chewie this is not going to
help me this won't help me then han and
Leia look at each other and they kissed
and like this is the last time they're
going to see each other grasp that
firmly Hans gonna get frozen in
something that resembles metal he's
gonna get sold to Jabba the Hutt they're
never gonna see each other ever again
they both know this the stormtroopers
pulling back to Leia breaks and she's
like I love you and Han Solo responds I
know one of the best moments ever made
and actually this is really interesting
in the script he was supposed to say I
love you too Harrison Ford was like I
don't think Han Solo would say that so
I'm going with I know director was like
yep I'm not George Lucas we're keeping
it and it worked perfectly I mean the
smoke comes up and Han Solo is frozen in
carbonite the smoke clears and you see
Vader's face coming through the smoke
just I'm like dude that is how you
portray a villain right there that is
villainy ladies and gentlemen and I find
it fascinating that Luke squaring off
with Vader for the first time is more
fascinating than the Death Star assault
in the first movie I mean you can tell
Luke is green you know and he pulls out
his lightsaber first which you know
there you go first mistake striking out
an anger Luke shame on you you can tell
Vader can waste him in any second he's
one hand blocking all his moves just
like you or no threat to me dude so
Luke's fighting Vader there's this one
scene where he backs up and falls into
the Carbonite freezing chamber Vader's
just like all too easy
it just activates it I'm like I like
that line too Vader's just like yeah was
Luke puts up enough of a fight where
there's this one scene where Vader comes
around a corner and he's slashing I'm
you can tell he's breathing hard he's
like I've had enough of this I'm
swinging now I'm gonna cut something off
and he does Luke loses his hand
Lucas failed Yoda's test han Solo has
been frozen in carbonite Boba Fett got
away with him and now Luke loses a hand
can this day get any worse yeah it's
about two Vader's telling Luke how
important Lucca is you know and with
their combined strength they can rule it
all then he cracks he's like alright I'm
not drilling through the wood here he
needs a bomb dropped on his lap so does
the audience and that's um Vader's like
I am your father and the way that music
queues up right there with the Imperial
March are like he ain't bluffing man I
think he's really is dad
yeah it's true Vader tells Luke we can
wipe out the Emperor and rule the galaxy
as father and son
Vader is like conniving and after that
Luke does probably the smartest thing
he's done in this entire movie I mean
he's been a whiner for the past two
movies you know you as the implausible
Yoda go into the cloud city when Yoda
told him not to because things are gonna
get worse Luke looks down at this big
long pit he's like you know what I'm out
and he just drops and he falls and yeah
he tried to kill himself he didn't know
that he would by chance get sucked into
a little tube that would lead to like
you know the TV antennas under the cloud
city or whatever those were Leia and
Chewie and all them they'd pick him up
and you don't even know yet this is like
the end of the movie they're all
standing looking at a galaxy within a
galaxy that's weird and then the movie
ends it's done this is like the
cliffhanger of the century or last
century everyone ends on a low note no
one ends on a high note the audience
just left with questions and
anticipation and then it's like boom end
credits done that's how you hook I'm
seeing three years my parents always
told me they were like yeah when we saw
that in the theaters that everyone was
like you've got to be [ __ ] me
no they [ __ ] you not that was the end of
the movie and thus is the conclusion of
one of the greatest movies ever made and
it is of course awesome tacular
yeah when the Empire Strikes Back oh
they strike back alright you blow up our
Death Star I'm gonna blow up your mind
and this is what I love about The Empire
Strikes Back the Empire Strikes Back is
the master movie I'm giving you enough
to satisfy you but not enough to not
want more you want more after that bite
Empire Strikes Back guys watch the Star
Wars movies just for the Empire Strikes
Back I'm telling you blow your mind when
everyone says all this movies the
greatest coming-of-age story ever and
they're talking about another movie
other than the Empire Strikes Back I
always come back to go and nope the
Empire Strikes Back is the greatest
coming-of-age story ever so what do you
think of the Empire Strikes Back how
does it compare to the other Star Wars
movies what's your favorite Star Wars
movie I probably asked you that and the
other Star Wars review but it doesn't
matter it's still relevant it's Empire
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more